from the time an event triggers you to
the time you're flooded with stress
hormones to the time you take a reaction
or you don't to the time the hormones
are flooded out of your body is 90
seconds you can't hold your anger that's
that over physiological response is 90
seconds so I asked her and I said so
Jill what does that mean why do people
stay angry for years and she said they
regenerated every 90 seconds so so every
90 seconds you're you have the ability
to say your your body is saying okay
here is a buffer you need me to be is
there still a threat is should I still
be stressed and you go like yeah but my
partner said this and you get angry
again and again and again for 90 seconds
and for most of us who are so creative
so you know your partner says something
hurtsful on a Friday on Saturday you say
he must be cheating on me on Sunday you
say all all the things I do for them but
you know they do they don't do for me
you and you can make it much worse we're
very very creative every 90 seconds and
that's why we stay unhappy that's why we
stay angry